thanks Marty I want to thank Ruth for
putting this together she does all the
work and I want to thank you for coming
it's always good to talk to real farmers
last winter if you were here we spent a
lot of time talking about water and
that's what it's all about is water and
if you look at what impact that we've
had with with no-till in South Dakota
and whatever it's all about water and
better utilizing the water and we
calculated a couple of years ago for the
Board of Regents who wanted to know what
the hell we did the board board of
directors of Dakota lakes got together
and we met with the Board of Regents and
we calculated the difference in crop
production in 1987 versus 2014 this was
in 2015 if we took the center of the
South Center and the and in the north
central crop reporting districts in
South Dakota basically that middle third
of the state of South Dakota in the
middle there we changed the farmers
change there we use the the Woolsey
price the night before Woolsey South
Dakota price we we changed the amount of
grain that they sold by one point six
billion dollars those are big numbers
unless you're in Washington but that's
big that's big numbers in South Dakota
that's a big increase in you and it's
it's the thing that I noticed from when
we first started doing this in 1990 till
now cities like Gettysburg that at one
time years ago in the 60s or whatever
when there's lots of babies had to two
classes in every grade in in the
elementary school and then they went to
one class in every grade and then all of
a sudden they're almost talking about
closing the school they're going back to
two classes and every grade again and I
think that's a good news and I think
part of that is how we produce things
and I'm going to kind of follow up a
little bit
with what Cody is doing and then I want
to talk about just some real basics a
lot of talk about soil health and muffin
fluff and whatever but they're just some
real basics to how you do how you do
no-till and it's and it's just real
simple stuff so we're going to talk
about a little bit of that and then you
can go home and get ready for the
blizzard
that's a Dakota Lakes right you know
that's our main station then we have
some soils to the north and if you're
not familiar actually that main station
the north those North two quarters right
in here those are what we call mill
Broyles which would be very similar to
what you see around Kennebec in that
area for you guys further east they're a
bit just a little bit better than the
peer soils and stuff you see out here in
some places and then the south side are
some pretty good less soils our North
unit has the old triple threat with
promise opal and sans arcs so those are
ones that you're familiar with some of
you guys here have none soils which are
really quite good soils actually and
then quite if you've formed some farms
and Pierce Pierce oils or something like
that a little trivia question for you
there's the soil call all our soils are
named after cities and whatever
localities right so the sand Sark is a
really shallow soil it's about a foot
and a half deep over fractured shale and
it's a put in half of that real clay
stuff the true virtus all just really
shallow
what's that named after well the sand
Sark soup right San Sark - tribe there's
a little city of San Sark there Craig
across the river from guess Gettysburg
but where does that name come from
it's French anybody here speak French
well in French saans means without Arc
means archery or bow and arrow so when
the first fur traders first came to that
area across the river from Gettysburg
the tribe they ran into there was it's
not using bows and arrows
still using Lance's so that's where that
name comes from it's kind of interesting
I always like to joke with my Native
American friends from that I said that
those guys were the conventional tillers
of the Indian society the last the last
Native Americans to adopt a new
technology right we still have people
doing conventional tillage here you
shouldn't be doing tillage here water is
too precious to you did a meeting
yesterday in Columbus Nebraska get 28
inches of rain a year well maybe they
can grow crops without saving water
there and then they got irrigated they
got irrigator sitting on fields there
where they get 28 inches of water a year
and rainfall what a bunch of pessimist
right okay this one are native
vegetation looks like we're going to go
to Australia Ruth's not gonna go to
Australia in about a month
and they have trees everywhere and they
have less rainfall than we have because
the rainfall comes in the wintertime
when it's cool and it goes deep past
because you're not using any water and
it all just moves deep and then you've
got trees okay so that the only place we
see trees is where there's a major
drainage way so the first time I went to
Australia I showed this slide somebody
in the audience went I said yes ma'am
she's worried the trees go I said Paul
Bunyan cut him down there's no idea of
Paul Bunyan why so you don't do that
that was a dumb thing to do so Ruth and
I went to France four years ago and we
did a kind of it we were in England
first that was fun and then we went to
France and they they got us a car that
had GPS that would speak English and we
would do a meeting I do a meeting from
8:00 till noon and then we'd hop in the
car and turn on GPS and go to the next
town and somebody meet us for supper and
show us around that town and we do
another meeting the next day and
whatever it's kind of
interesting trip but every town we went
to they had to show us their castle so
we went looked at the castle when you
got the grain bins and got and they all
kind of looked pretty impressive and
took a lot of energy to build them and
and a lot of work and a lot of wealth
and whatever and you you know you go in
and now you got the grain bins there
where did where did you produce the
grain that went in the grain bins they
said well on the land right around the
castle so you look over the wall and it
was so degraded it wouldn't even grow
bushes very well and you'd point that
out that maybe that was one of the
reasons it's no longer castle and when
we looked at their soils this is what
they look like and this is what they
look like
and they're still plowing them and
they're plowing them deeper and they're
plowing up and down the hills and
there's places are plowing down the
hills because they can't plow across the
hills and they can't plow up the oats
that can't pull it so they drive up and
plow down and so I I started the
discussion by saying my ancestors left
Europe to come to the United States
because they degraded the soil so badly
that they had in Europe that they had to
go someplace else and find soils that
weren't degraded and then I said they've
done a good job of degrading the soils
that they find in the US ok this area is
part of the Louisiana Purchase Louisiana
Purchase happened because they're the
Lavi Andre brothers came from Winnipeg
Manitoba they were fur traders and they
came across the Continental Divide in
eastern North Dakota if you didn't know
there is one there is one there between
the Red River drainage and the Missouri
River drainage right there between
Valley City Inn and Jamestown there's a
Continental Divide it's about this high
okay and and they came across that
Continental Divide that came down the
Missouri River and they buried lead
plates in different areas of around here
we don't know how many they built they
buried but one was buried just above
Fort Pierre and you can see that one in
in the the Heritage Museum and it
claimed this area for France that was 17
43 so the white man had been here quite
a while you know pretty pretty actually
before the Revolutionary War we had
white guys running around out here
claiming they're here for France you
know pretty optimistic guys there too
and in the our founding fathers George
Washington Thomas Jefferson and those
guys were way back in the early part of
our nation the late 70s 1700s a few
years more increased surreality will
drive the inhabitants of the Atlantic
states westward for support
they were degrading the soils and they
knew that and they were trying to figure
out what to do about it whereas if they
were taught how to improve the old
instead of going on to in pursuit of the
new and productive soils they would make
these acres which now scarcely yield him
anything turned out beneficial to
themselves George Washington he and
Thomas Jefferson had lots of
conversation about how stupid it was
that they continued to degrade the soils
that's 300 200 whatever years ago David
Montgomery wrote a book dirt if you
haven't read it it's kind of interesting
reading this photo here was taken in
South Dakota in the 1930s because we
were doing that when I went to
Gettysburg in the 1970s to teach high
school chemistry not not AG dejan
chemistry people don't understand that
you couldn't be assured that you would
make it to Pierre and back if you left
Gettysburg go to Pierre in the
wintertime you wouldn't be assured
you're going to get home if the wind
started to blow because everybody was
doing wheat and summer fell in that
country okay talking about his dirt book
at a meeting and they said you know in
the teachers line I mean
speakers loans that you have at these
bigger conferences I sat down with him I
said you know you really should come and
revisit that area north appear again and
see what's happened there because it's
changed and he comes subsequently wrote
this book growing a revolution which has
a chapter about some of the guys in that
area in fact my carnal teas in that in
that book they talked about his his
operation okay but anyway Thomas
Jefferson realized that they had to do
something so in 1803 he bought the
Louisiana Purchase and then he sent
Lewis and Clark up the river right
here's where two cold Lakes is by the
way right in there but they came through
here so we know what this land looked
like before before we got here and start
screwing it up but what they were
looking for were beavers was the first
thing that's what the lobby hunters
weren't looking for beavers and they
took all the beavers out well what were
the beavers doing here all these dams
and all these little tributaries all the
way from Black Hills down down River
through Missouri whatever so you take
all the beavers out then you send the
settlers in and the settlers start to do
tillage they cut down with few trees
there are and they start over grazing
and we have flooding now what should the
response be put the Beavers back and
quit doing that stuff you're doing right
no no we're we're not that smart so
we're gonna put in large main stem
reservoirs we're European males right
that's what we do we go put in large
main stem reservoirs we've got four in
South Dakota they're gonna they're gonna
give us 500,000 acres of irrigation over
around Redfield because that was flat in
the 1930s and 40s you can't irrigate
land that's rolling you have to have
this stuff that you can run the water
down between the rows and we all know
that you couldn't produce corn and
soybeans at Redfield without irrigation
for God's sake and it's kind of like
Nebraska they don't think they can
produce anything without irrigation
ray did you notice that so they built a
big dam and they build a big power plan
and they built an irrigation pump
station that's never been used and they
built a whole bunch of canals so I I
show people the canals when they come to
visit if they're going the right
direction we show them this huge huge
canals that were built to take the water
from the Missouri River over to the Jim
River but when I went to red field in
1983 and by there a Ray managed the same
farm I managed it the one at red field
one time in its existence we both had
the same major professor in our PhDs
we have a lot of parallels but when I
went to red field in 1983 there was
nineteen hundreds of soybeans and
and Brown County combined and I made the
mistake on my PhD orals to say that I
thought if we no tilled we could
probably grow corn and soybeans in the
Jim River Valley without irrigation and
Larry fine whoo-hoo ray remembers nobody
else does but he thought I didn't
understand water very well so he he
really made my life miserable for an
hour or so in my orals but he lived long
enough to see no-till and different crop
production move into the Jim River
Valley which now those two counties are
the number one number two corn producing
counties in the state and I was told
before we came to Pierre that we would
never produce hundred bushel dryland
corn it in used County I was told that
George and I made a bet on it so we won
that bet several years in a row before
the guy to say he didn't want to do that
anymore but it just it talks to the idea
of we haven't in the old days we didn't
use water well the thing that we have
done no-till is just a tool the thing
we're doing is using water better that's
really what we're about so in 1973 we
had a whole bunch of guys got all
excited about the Russian wheat deal
energy prices were low 1970
and interest rates were low in 1973
everybody started putting in irrigation
along the Missouri River it's because
somebody had invented a center pivot we
didn't need to we didn't need to have a
level ground to irrigate anymore so
these guys start pumping water out of
the Missouri River and irrigating and it
ran promptly back down the hill into the
river because our soils were these wind
blowing less soils and they when they
got tilled which everybody said to grow
irrigated corn you got to have it black
and then we put water on it just look
like this floor and that's kind of when
I entered the scene have tried to figure
out how to stop runoff under irrigate
errs and that's where those efforts led
to a meeting after a field day one night
at Bob Steakhouse where people said we
really need to have more research effort
long the center in the western part of
the state and another guy said well I'll
get my brother-in-law who's in the
legislature to get you some land and I
said why don't you leave your
brother-in-law alone let's see if we
can't get our own land instead of having
the state own it so we can control it so
that's the way that started its own and
directed by farmers all fixed facilities
of land and much of the irrigation
equipment owned by the corporation and
things like that right again the
comparison of corn soybeans spring late
winter wheat and sunflower production
those three areas increased by one point
six billion in 2014 as compared to 1986
we didn't do that because we set out to
improve yields the goal was to better
manage our water because that's what
we're having trouble with we weren't
getting the water in the ground better
manage your nutrients and this is what
this whole movements about whether you
call it soil health that you call it
no-till or you whatever you call it it's
about better managing the ecosystem we
have to do a better job or we're going
to end up looking like the Europeans
where they're totally degraded soils
we've only been at this for 200 years so
what we did is
look at how the native systems work
because they water goes in the ground
and native systems and you don't have
the salty spots and native systems
normally and we call this a
transformational change or a holistic
report approach I stole this from Jay
Fuhrer who said he stole it from
somebody else but it's one of my
favorite statements the light bulb did
not result by incrementally making
candles better you know you think about
that it's just go okay yeah that makes
sense
you know back and often and so what
we've been doing a lot of times in
agriculture were just incrementally
changing what is really a system that's
been broken since it was in Europe
instead of just saying now this is
stupid let's do something else
farmer manages ecosystem take sunlight
water and carbon dioxide and makes them
into products to be sold and we look at
this water cycle energy flow mineral
cycle community dynamics and there's
lots of places where we have talked
about how we do that does the brain feed
plants and recharge groundwater or
runoff or deep percolate if you're
running your water off and you live at
wall you that's a problem you don't want
to do that okay yeah that's what's wrong
here we can now put on 2 inches of water
in 9 minutes with our irrigate errs and
we have nothing runoff and if you come
into summertime and many of you've been
there we walk in behind those irrigate
errs and it totally changes your way of
looking at things and it's because we
have this armor we don't have the armor
there because we think that's cute it's
there because it protects the soil keeps
the weeds from going keeps the soil cool
does all these things people so I really
like to use that big hole opener makes
that wheat grow better well now you have
no more armor ok you gotta have that
armor and that that that whole process
starts it
there's where earthworms live they're
protected for anybody has been around
irrigation this is 20 years we
tract if you've been around irrigation
those things always had big ruts in them
and when we first started doing this we
had our Board of Directors from the coal
lakes the guys that were irrigating
we're irrigating with tillage come to
Redfield one day and we had a lateral
move they're running on some no-till
drop and we went out to look at crops
and I'm walking along I'm talking
together
yeah then turn around I have no farmers
behind me they're all lightened up on
one of my wheel tracks going why isn't
that deeper and I hadn't really ever
thought about that you know they didn't
set out to make shallow wheel tracks and
they noticed it because there's weren't
that way take the e out of it
evapotranspiration ET the evaporation
makes you know money when you make the
water go through a plant it makes you
money when you make it let it just float
off the surface it doesn't make you any
money so one of the ideas behind this
forage cover cropping thing is to try to
take something that would have to
evaporate to make it dry enough for you
to plant or whatever and make it go
through go through a plant and yesterday
at in Nebraska we had two young farmers
that were on a panel and they're both
talking about well you know one of the
things I really like now than a no-till
would that cover crops and whatever I
can drive in that field anytime we want
to and I don't think in that don't make
rice and all that kind of stuff doesn't
happen year one but they've noticed now
that that is starting to happen make
water in or the soil and then maximize
the water holding capacity by building
the organic matter we've talked about
those things today this is a good idea
for irrigation is a great idea for those
without irrigation like you guys so most
of our impact has actually been on the
non irrigation part of of the country
most of the guys that were irrigating in
in nineteen seventy six have quit
because their lifts are too high and
they grow they make more money per
dollar invested by far on their dry land
they would
irrigation irrigation is expensive and
it costs you a lot of money everyday and
it and it's it it's high management and
it gets obsolete and it has issues
there's places where a Geisha makes
sense but you shouldn't be competing as
you know and tell you tell you've used
every drop of water that Mother Nature
gives you as efficiently as you can you
shouldn't even think about irrigation
ecosystems harvest sunlight right and
that drive all other processes sunlight
energy that's stored in the residue
removing these products from the
ecosystem reduces the energy available
so if you're taking off all your residue
which they are in a lot of places
there's nothing to drive that soil
biology everybody keeps talking about
the soil biology well the soil biology
you've got to feed them and they eat
residue got a guy from Iowa called me
that day and they gonna harvest his corn
they're gonna take all he's a dairy you
got agreement with the dairy he's gonna
harvest these corn and then they're
gonna take cut off and rake up and Bale
all these corn stalks and he says I want
to continue the no-till my soybeans how
do I do that we've got a lot more things
to discuss and just how you're gonna
know tell your soybean that's one of the
reasons we're doing the thing with
livestock it has to do with the residue
and cycling the residue so there's one
of our cover crops that mixture of
barley oats and peas and whatever and we
slice that you've seen these photos
there's winter wheat growing back in
there so we got the living root it was
in winter wheat during the summer but we
also have winter wheat going back there
and it'll be there next spring and then
we'll kill it before we plant the corn
in this case and this that thing stays
nice and green in there one of the
things that I don't know if Cody
mentioned it but the stuff we bailed
this year those wasps we be able to make
the comparison so we have the residue
remove stuff so that's waswas pretty wet
when we bailed it but it was a wet fall
and and so we've had to feed those bales
because they were going bad whereas a
swath is fine
finding the really bad stuff and that's
velocity of the day no day went in
really wet because of the wet fall sauce
it when it's pretty wet it's fine so
there's there's our our mamas and their
babies eating their swass but the
question always comes up there's a swath
get spread out if you move that thing a
little bit every day they clean it right
up but you can see the are more steel in
there that swath reat stubble still and
they leave that alone
it lays down and everybody's happy okay
more cows more goats more sheep number
one meat eaten in the world is goat okay
so and they're good at getting rid of
Candida thistle
so you might want to get excited about
this but there's no way to feed the
people in the world in the future if
we're going to take me to way the only
way to take marginal land and turn it
into human edible protein produce human
edible protein on upgrade the protein is
to use ruminant animals and anybody that
tries to tell you that we're going to
have fake meat and all this stops they
can't make feet fake meat on marginal
land okay so if you're going to feed
people we're going to have to use the
animals which is fine that's what we
should be doing anyway 100% grass-fed
ground beef certified USDA where was
this produced well we get some cows from
Montana than never seen grain doesn't
know what grain looks like some coal
cows you haul them to them place in
central or eastern South Dakota and you
put them on cover crops and you fatten
them on cover crops you take them in
Omaha and you make them in hamburger
okay so this is actually being done
okay I don't know why me having trouble
with that I'm probably doing something
goofy all tillage tools Detroit destroys
soil structure all tillage tools
decreased water infiltration all tillage
tools reduce organic matter and all
tillage tools increase weeds 27,000
gallons of water with one percent
organic matter in six inches of soil
that's 1/4 of an inch of water we can
increase the organic matter by four
percent we've put in an extra inch in
the top six inches and extra 2 inches on
top foot grandpa had more organic matter
than you do
he came here because it had a high
organic matter he mined it that's fine
now you have to quit doing that
what about pests well let's talk about
aphids given the high rate of
reproduction by aphid certain levels
continue increase all summer a
photography males that give birth to
pregnant females see you know all the
guys in the in the audience should be
afraid because you could be out of
business if you're in the aphid world if
your next reincarnation you're born is
an aphid you're really trouble so
pregnant females that give birth to
pregnant females you should grow high
populations but we don't because a fat
population dynamics depend on levels of
natural enemies temperature and that
kind of thing
7 spotted lady beetle females 8 on
average 100 15 soybean aphids in 24
hours a male eat 78 the end starts of
little things that look like dragons 8
105 the other kind eats 95 males 54 not
quite as hungry great so when you go to
check on me a fridge you got in your
weed or how many aphids you got in your
soybeans you also count 2 ladybugs wait
a week walk at the farm a few years ago
and the entomologist was saying oh well
he's way above thresholds and I smiled
and whatever and we went home that night
rooster
not gonna spray are you I said well I'm
gonna look at a Monday because I have
lots of lady birds in there and the
temperature was going to get hot Monday
or Tuesday they're all gone okay so no
one knows the number one thing that
kills a foot is fungi 84% soybean aphids
got whacked by this one fungi so if we
know the number one thing that kills
aphids is fungi number two are these
predators and somebody tells you if
we're going to come out and spray some
herbicide now why don't we just throw a
little fungicide a little insecticide in
that and it just doesn't cost very much
and it can't do any harm see you're
gonna kill all your predator
seven species of aphid found seven
species of Asian pathogenic fungi were
found in them in 2003 and for overuse of
fungicide can cause insect outbreaks if
we use too many fungicides you kill you
kill the the predatory fungi so we had
this cover crop few years ago my
neighbor come over and we were you know
it was what a pollinator type thing it
was a mustard and it's all flowering
just full of bugs
he's aren't you gonna spray this I said
why would I spray this see what his bugs
in here most bugs are good bugs some of
these weren't good bugs but I didn't
want to harvest his crop anyway I said
I'm feeding my predators so I'm gonna
have predators around next year when the
when the bad bugs show up I got to feed
him something to keep him around and let
them have babies and stuff so they're
ready right over-reliance and herbicides
leads to resistant weeds and maybe
disease problems everybody talks about
these resistant weeds one of the
problems we have is we have too many
bacterial diseases now because we use
surfactants too frequently the things
like bacterial leaf spot and whatever
what what bacteria do is they penetrate
into leave if you put a surfactant on a
week in the wax you're going
get more disease fungicides herbicides
and insecticides have collateral damage
their disturbance to the system ray
mentioned chloride when we get a
chloride we always put a little chloride
on with our wheat because chloride helps
the wheat protect itself from disease so
we don't have to put the fungicide on so
we just put a little bit on there so it
has high high chloride concentration
high disturbance techniques HOH drills
and such and in vertical tillage
increase weed pressure and cause soil
erosion and this this is tillage erosion
we pull the top of the hills down as I
came north from Columbus yesterday up
through Norfolk and in the Yankton came
home that way have all these big rolling
less hills down there blew up by the
Missouri River bottom and they're still
doing tillage on them and the tops of
the hills are going down to the bottom I
couldn't believe they were still doing
that okay the way we control pests is we
use sanitation rotation and competition
pesticides are only part of Sanitation
to keep weeds from going to seed for
instance they're only part of rotation
what I want to do in terms of
competition is to keep a weed small
enough that my crop can compete with it
fertilizer placement ray doesn't care
about fertilizer placement I do because
I don't want my weeds to have it so I'm
going to place my fertilizer either in a
place or a time when it's not going to
benefit to weed something like Palmer
amaranth is a huge and feeder and if you
if you broadcast nitrogen on you're just
feeding the wheat so we're gonna place
our fertilizer three inches from the
corn row at the same depth or the
sorghum roll
I don't care where its roots are II just
don't want the weeds to get to it so I'm
going to put it where the plant my plant
my beneficial plant can compete with the
weeds ecosystem the lake nutrients for
extended periods of time become deserts
saline seats and you have some of them
out here is because we aren't using and
cycling the water in the nutrient
like it should be a nutrient placement
is part of cycling
I'm a farmer takes sunlight water and
carbon dioxide and make products that I
can sell and Ray said to me earlier
today in a private conversation what we
need to do is be getting to the point
where we're selling stuff instead of
selling commodities selling stuff that
we can sell in the internet you guys all
know how to do that
that's old guys don't know how to do
that but young guys not do that so we're
going to produce something and sell it
and there's people that want to buy
stuff that's produced sustainably or
regenerative Lee or whatever at a half
an hour conversation the other day on a
telephone on the way down to Nebraska I
stopped on top of Hill had a half an
hour conversation to the person in
charge of sustainability for Cargill ok
and we've got to be able to give them a
product state that we can defend and say
this is done the right way
the best environmental way the best food
safety way and and this is the way we do
it focus on having the soil wet during
the dry part of the year instead of just
focusing on having it dry during wet
part of the year so you can be the first
guy to get done planting right and you
know it
every year people come and I got a
neighbor that works a heck out of his
ground and sometimes his corns bigger
than mine
the last week in the June last Thursday
in June most time it isn't but sometimes
it is and guys a look at things away his
corns bigger than yours and I used to go
through a long explanation now I just
say oh I didn't know you harvested corn
in June and I turn around and walk away
and then kind of Bend the end of that
conversation focus on having the soil
cool during the hot part of the year
roots don't like it hot and they don't
do a good job of taking up nutrients if
they're hot that cover that armor
it keeps the soil cool so we can have it
cool during that hot part of the year
that's important to irrigation people
it's imperative to rain-fed farming
mother nature's an opportunist if you
have a problem weed
these insect I don't care you provide
the opportunity somewhere in your system
here's resistant kosher that we
developed on purpose in the early 1990s
to prove we could it's resistant to
pursuit because I said I predicted that
was going to happen the company
threatened to lawsuit if I didn't
retract so I just developed my own and
then that negated that whole lawsuit
thing that's that's kosher right there
that's chickpeas hiding in there just
for my carnally that's sick t-mike but
we didn't have much at that period of
time to control anything in chickpeas he
surely couldn't use it now the cross
compliant the cross resistance came
because those kosha I went and got from
somebody that had been overusing glean
so it's not just a pursuit thing it's
all oversight said if we don't use them
properly
now what happens there oh here let's
look at the how this happens if in the
old days and you guys used to have a
little bit of downy Brome here you don't
have it anymore right it's gone Scott
you don't have any cheatgrass scene
where do you he's just grinning but that
used to be a huge problem because it did
a rotation that provided huge
opportunities and randiandersen
made this statement two years of warm
season crops or a fallow unusual warm
season crop and a fallow reduced number
seeds by 95% so we did wheat corn fallow
the old eco fallow thing we could take
care of cheatgrass same thing happens
with warm season weeds like the Palmer
amaranth or waterhemp or something like
that and the reason that works is let's
take foxtail it emerges Palmer arm
amaranth same time after the corns plan
that goes to flower before the corn is
harvested so it has its whole lifecycle
here and it can compete in the early
phases if I put winter wheat in that
thing hasn't emerged winter we weed has
full canopy and it it's harvested before
that thing goes to flower and you can
control it just very simple thing we had
long term rotation study maybe some of
you remember that
warm and cool season crops everything
was done no-till is in linemen counting
on some promise tiles we did that for 12
years and in the 13th year Randy
Anderson came out we had a what we had
to do was was planted all uniformly to a
wheat crop which we did and he came out
and counted the number of weeds in the
different rotations where we did week
chickpea for 12 years he found 94 weeds
where we did wheat corn chickpea found
40 where we did a more diverse rotation
that he found seven Clara Seamus who
allow do you still remember had a
similar type study where he used in
anhydrous tonight for once every four
years other than that he was no tilling
and he had a loader he had a high
diversity sunflower wheat corn spring
wheat and he had a low diversity wheat
millet rotation and and Randy did the
same thing with his and what we found
was the same trend highest with a low
diversity Louis with high diversity
rotation but since I didn't do any
disturbance I did better the real
comparison there is tillage and poor
rotation 225 weeds per square yard or
square meter no-till and good rotation 7
weeks
97% weed control just with cultural
practices that has to do with
disturbance so if you're thinking well
dad just gonna go out and disc a little
bit right I mean one of the one of the
things I used to tell guys cuz they'd
want to start no tilling but dad didn't
want or the uncle didn't want to get rid
of the machinery
just in case we might need it I said
fine ok just tell them you'll do that
but you know to protect some tires and
hydraulic cylinders take the height
tires off and hydraulic cylinders off
before you park it over in the edges and
then they really won't be tempted to
start up and go out and screw with it
when you go on vacation right so because
that used to happen at times kid goes on
vacation dad goes disc bunch around just
just to make it better
he took Green Fox Hill place at 3 deaths
in the soil zero two and four inches and
he looked at
number of live seeds yearly okay
after two years if he left it on the
surface only 11 percent were still alive
buried 2 inches 28 percent buried four
inches 55% if you're doing disturbance
are constantly digging up and burying
and makin seeds go dormant you can't
control the weed seed bank so to prove
that even further we took four places at
Dakota Lakes I let little areas go to
all the weeds grow and go to seed once
and then he tilled a small area and left
a small area you're not not tilled and
then when we put herbicide on these
areas we put a tarp over top of them so
they never got herbicides on them and he
counted the seedlings yearly for three
years okay first you're not much
different from tilled in no-till second
year not much difference it's when you
have that two year break that you get
the big difference corn pea winter wheat
corn if you got a weed that goes to seed
in the corn that you really can't
control in corn you can get rid of
ninety-six percent of it if you're just
doing every other year you can't so
there's a typical thing if we drive a
little wide with our winter wheat or
don't really get a runaway in terms of
weeds so real quickly rotation types
simple rotations this is the one most
people think about wheat corn canola
spring wheat winter wheat corn sunflower
corn soybean wheat fallow whatever
they're simple they're predictable
limited number of crops the managing
market this is what a lot of people are
doing but they're very predictable to
the insects and such rotations with
perennial sequences which I think we're
going to have to use we're going to have
to put those deep roots in that Cody was
talking about and we can if we we can do
a stupid rotation for about six years
and then put it in a perennial for three
or four or the only thing I don't like
about this is I'd rather see grasses in
there but there's lots of examples of
those limited number annual crops
demands your market excellent place to
spread manure if you
spread manure you can probably produce
more soil structure with annual than
annual crops because the grass specially
the grass mixtures disadvantage you've
got a Cody pointed out today that we got
that new rotation we started we're only
putting in a perennial five years out of
20 now I'm not sure that's enough okay
compound rotations where we take two
rotations and make them into simple
rotations make them more complex we were
talking about one of these at noon
spring late winter wheat corn soybean
corn soybean half the corn is behind
soybeans and half the corns behind wheat
if you're over in the Jim River Valley
that's probably a good good rotation for
you because you can grow pretty good
corn behind soybeans as you get further
west you can't do that you got to have
more moisture I call this a
mother-in-law a blanket rotation because
the mother-in-law banker comes to visit
you in June you show them this corn
planted in the soybean looks great if
they come in August or September most
likely you'll take him out and show them
the stuff that was in the in the wheat
stubble okay still have a limited number
of crops to manage creates more than one
sequence for some crop types if you grow
corn behind beans every year you're
going to get corn rootworm beetles at
five from the corn field the soybean
fields to lay their eggs that's happened
in Eastern Corn Belt if we grow if
everybody here grew corn behind wheat we
would get corn rootworm apply to the
wheat stubble to lay their eggs so we
got to try to be not predictable
complex rotations we're crop to the same
crop type varies so we started putting
in bill barley instead of to wheats we
got barley or oats we got most sunflower
and pea that kind of thing has some
advantages very capable creating a wide
array of crop type by sequence
combinations sorghum and corn have
advantages and disadvantages but they
complement each other
it takes a lot more crop management
skills but this is why we pay you guys
the big bucks right it's not you got to
have the management skills it's not
because you can drive a tractor straight
anymore because I got auto steer so now
how the tractors going across the field
you can work on your management stacked
rotations is the one that surprised us
and that we developed and we didn't
really realize the power until laters
where we put the same crop or crop type
twice in a row and the idea is to do
that to get the long break the secret
here is the long break to let that weed
population go down right and so and once
it's down it takes a couple of years for
it to come back up again so we do two
and then get out of there and we got a
four year break before we come back to
that crop again okay we keep the pest
population diverse or confused diversity
in sequence and intervals its mix along
and sort residual herbicide programs for
you guys out here if you're afraid of
atrazine because the low rainfall if you
stack to warm season grasses corn or
sorghum or millet one after the other
you can use a higher rate of atrazine in
the first one that's one of the most
powerful things you can do it's cheap
atrazine is cheap and you can do that
kind of stuff and especially if you're
doing grazing things ok 2 year break
between corn and wheat so you don't have
to worry about the head scab thing but
the goal is to allow sufficient time for
press pressures declined to very low
levels before sequencing the crop or
crop type 2 times and we can reduce the
rest of developing bio type resistance
we grew the cost of herbicide programs
some crop sequences may not be ideal we
really don't stack broad leaves very
often but the goal is to be in
inconsistent in both sequence and
interval so look at your rotation same
there how predictable am i right to you
it might look predictable to insects I
mean if you're just doing something that
allows them to develop some habit in the
in the court in the Western Corn Belt
for instance corn-soybean guys now have
corn rootworm beetles where the eggs
don't hatch for two years instead of
hatching first year because it's always
one year so they figured that one out
that's why they've got to use BT and all
that stuff where we don't have to here's
some rotations utilizing most actin and
in normal sequences canola winter wheat
corn the two corns and then the rest of
it's not stacked we got one we use on
the farm on the north unit where we do
two eats a pea and then we do a sorghum
corn actually up there and then and then
pea I guess that's one here right here
when our wheat winter wheat sunflower
sorghum corn pea and this one really is
a some kind of an oil seeped might be
flax whatever dryland rotations again
those that's where those at you'll be
able to get these slides too but there's
no set recipe or best rotation the
everybody needs to pick their own it's
going to vary with fields it's going to
vary with if your neighbor has resistant
kosher and he lets it blow across yeah
it's going to vary with a lot of things
and including you know your personal
lifestyle wouldn't when do you want to
have a little vacation time in the
summer or whatever show you a few slides
there's a rotation in 2006 that wheat
let didn't look very good 2006 very dry
year and right across the road that's
what the winter wheat looked like what
was the difference there and you can see
it from an aerial photo the good-looking
wheat was in this corn pea winter wheat
had been in that rotation since 1990
this was 2006 and this one was soybean
corn pea winter wheat half broadleafs
half low residue we didn't have the
armor and look at that week okay what's
it mean in yields 2006 60 versus 29
bushel 7.9 inches of rain from the time
we harvested two peas until we harvested
the wheat in 2005 when we got 23 inches
92 versus 50
seven in 2002 which is the first time
this happened 6.4 inches in a year
56 versus 28 I can't afford to do I hear
this all the time I can't afford to grow
yes I can't afford to do this I've got
to do the high a value of things I've
got to do the low residue things could
it make me more money they don't make
you more money if you look at this type
of response this rotation just doesn't
have enough high residue so we've taken
the soybeans out Cody mentioned this and
now we put we have these this three way
just looks like this three way same
thing other than we have a five-year
perennial sequence in there and in 17 or
18 years we're going to have good
information and when I explained that to
Cody one day said you better keep riding
your bicycle if you're going to be
around here to watch that what happens
where there is lots of water surely they
don't need to worry about this right so
corn corn soybean wheat soybean
first-year soybeans 76 bushels second
year soybeans 81 this is under
irrigation if I just do corn soybeans I
get sixty two point nine bushel so if I
average those two from the other one
seventy eight point eight versus sixty
two point nine so the guy doing corn
soybeans is getting less soybean yields
how about corn yields well continuous
corn we've had corn in one field since
1990 it's about two hundred three bushel
the acre average type thing corn
soybeans to seventeen corn corn soybean
wheat soybean the two corns average the
first ones like 250 or so the second
ones 217 or 220 235 okay so what if I
grew 5,000 acres of that I get a million
bushels if I got 5,000 acres of corn I
got a million bushels of corn and a
big-ass dryer lot
the trucks I mean wow but there's guys
that do that and think they make money
okay corn-soybean I got 2500 acres of
corn I got 2500 acres of soybeans corn
corn soybean wheat soybean I got 2,000
acres of corn 2,000 acres of soybeans on
thousand acres of wheat and there's the
bushels okay would you trade 7,200
bushels of corn for 120,000 bushels of
wheat today see that's what the numbers
show yeah and that can't afford to do
anything but corn soybean I produce more
bushels of soybeans on 2,000 acres of
soybeans in this rotation than you do on
2,500 acres of soybeans on that rotation
interesting can't afford to do that with
all grain over here can't afford not to
first time I went to Argentina they were
doing seven years of pastures and seven
years of cropping and then there
cropping was no-till with cover crops
and diversity corn wheat beans and I had
a friend of mine we dug out a little bit
of soil and he held it up and if you
want to talk about what is a healthy
soil that's a healthy soil and then they
outlawed the export of beef get rid of
the beef thing can export beef keep all
the beef for the poor people well guys
the poor people can't eat enough beasts
they can't pay enough for it so the guy
started got rid of the beef and started
growing soybeans on soybeans I went back
in 2006 and it looked like this exactly
the same fuel and went back a year ago
that's last fall they haven't change
that yet and now they have lake showing
up where they never had lakes they have
rivers showing up where there were never
rivers because they've got the water
cycle broken so bad knee
we can't expect our governments and our
companies and whatever to understand the
importance of maintaining our soil
resource we have to do this ourselves
organic matter makes a difference
there's our daughters who are much older
than that now
and one of them might come by often in
here pretty soon but this is a prairie
plant and and and Cody's showed you one
of those right compare that to what you
get with wheat and whatever and that
cycles these nutrients back to the
surface of your ph's are dropping your
light you got lying down here but you
keep pushing it down goes sideways
becomes a Saline seat bring it back up
get it on the surface but if you haul
that off and take it to a feedlot Cody
showed you that too today that nutrient
doesn't get back to the fields all
tillage tools are soy so structural
tillage tools decreased water
infiltration right people I got to
vertical tillage thing I got this
tillage thing got that thing though it
works great no it does it
Mother Nature doesn't do tillage till
they just agriculture what fracturing is
to petroleum they both increase the
speed and extent of nutrient removal
from the resource leaving the resource
degraded that's not what we're about
we're not miners I did ask the North
Dakota and the Alberta people and I was
there earlier this year what's the hurry
why don't you leave some of that some of
that oil there for your grandkids I mean
do you not like your descendants why are
you mad at them why do you got to get
rid of it all right away I mean you
don't think we're going to use some of
that down the road 100 200 years okay
some expert proposed using tillage as a
means to address weeds resistance if
tillage was so good at getting rid of
weeds they should all be gone by now and
that goes through the science of that
but I'm not going to okay thank you very
much you've been a pleasure
[Applause]
you